okay a little change of pace today with
our uh new video which is sponsored by
the way by home title lock but more
about that
in a little bit we're gonna check in
with reddit's parenting advice forum
uh we we've gone through relationship
questions on reddit
and now we're gonna we're gonna see if
we can sort through some of the
quandaries
snafus plights and predicaments the
reddit parents
find themselves in and i'll see if
there's any
any advice that i can offer any clarity
i can offer let's jump right into it
here's the first question it says i have
two boys eight and nine
i'm rather laid back as a parent they
can typically do what they want as long
as they're done with their homework
brush their teeth etc i typically don't
ground them often usually if they were
fighting or didn't do homework
they're pretty good boys and i don't
have to ground them often a day or two
for a given month
my wife tells me that grounding slash
timeouts is abuse
and i need to let them face the natural
consequences of their actions like
smelling bad or not getting good grades
i'm a strong believer in positive
reinforcement but also i think you need
some sort of negative reinforcement tool
for when it doesn't work absolutely no
punishment seems a couple steps
too far am i wrong okay a couple things
here
number one your kid's smelling bad is
not a consequence to him that's a
consequence to everybody else that's a
consequence to everyone has to be around
your kid you're punishing everyone in
the vicinity of your child
kids don't care if they smell bad have
you ever have you ever actually smelled
a room full of third graders especially
after recess
it's it is rough stuff so that's the
first thing second
you say you don't ground them often
usually only if they're fighting
so you mean that you ground them every
day because they're eight and
nine-year-old brothers they're
definitely gonna fight all the time
not as often as say a 12 and 14 year old
pair of sisters would fight
or even like a 32 and 34 year old pair
of sisters but still
they're going to fight a lot third thing
most importantly yes you need to punish
your child
see your job as a parent part of your
job anyway is to prepare your children
for
adulthood so let me ask you
is adult life a place where there's only
positive reinforcement is that the only
kind of
enforcement you're gonna find it's
positive reality is full of negative
reinforcement
that's reality's whole thing that's
life's whole thing
95 of the enforcement in in in life from
reality is negative
that's science right there so yes you
want to ground your kids prepare your
kids
for that reality now so that they don't
become
the sorts of entitled brats that we all
have to deal with speaking of punishing
everybody else
you don't want your kid to become a
smelly disgusting entitled brat that's
the point
okay this says my son is eight and a
half and acts like it's a damn chore to
go play outside
he's very into legos xbox and hot wheels
which is fine
but i'm a firm believer in kids being
outside he has a bike scooter electric
scooter a freaking go-kart and a
hoverboard
and every time i recommend him going
outside to do one of those things
he lets out a pouty sigh i am so over it
how do i get him to engage in more
outside play take away his xbox
he only plays it three times a week
maybe suggestions how is this a question
what's the controversy here yes take
away the xbox
next question why do you have to think
about that
your kid's playing the xbox too much um
you want him to go outside he's not
no don't don't buy him more electric
gadgets to play with outside that's not
the right way
he doesn't need that there are trees
outside you can go climb
there's grass that he can roll around in
yes you take the xbox away and you don't
give it back either
what i'll i'll never understand parents
who worry about this kind of thing
well i could afford what happens if i
take the phone away what happens if i
take the xbox away
they'll be mad at me they might beat me
up he's eight years old
just take it away he should be playing
with in the first place it's not making
his life any better
how is the xbox making your
eight-year-old's life any better it's
not
this to me is not this is so not an
issue for me as a parent
if the kids have a toy that they're
fighting over i take it away if they're
playing with it too much and not going
outside i take it away
they've been watching tv too too long i
turn it off
tell them go outside they say i don't
want to go outside i don't care go
outside
do i need to pick you up and bring you
outside and shut the door because i will
this one says i'm a mum to a
four-year-old and a one-year-old
the problem is my biggest that doesn't
like to spend time with me and cries
when his dad goes out
and i don't think he loves me i try to
play but he whines instantly and fights
with his brother
therefore i grab my mobile and um that's
british for phone
by the way and i stopped focusing on him
we're staying almost
all day together and he is driving me
crazy
he never acts this way with anyone but
me i try to cheer him up but it always
fails and i'm stuck with it with whining
24 7.
i also don't sleep at night because his
brother wakes me up every hour and his
behavior is making me cry
every day if his dad is around he'll
stop whining and play but
every two or three days i'm faced with
the same problem i try to distract him
from the crying
but i have a lot of responsibilities too
and anytime i spend time with him he
ends up angry on some small stuff
it's making me fear the times i spend
with him please help okay let's go back
to this sentence because i i feel like
this is a big sentence
there's a lot in this sentence right
here where you said
i try to play but he whines instantly
and fights with his brother
therefore i grab my phone and stop
focusing on it
so you try to play with him he instantly
whines
and so you grab your phone well i gave
you a chance four year old
back to twitter i'm thinking you've
confused the chicken
and the egg here we've got a classic
dilemma
is it that your four-year-old doesn't
want to spend time with you
or is it that you don't want to spend
time with him and he's picking up on
that
so is he rejecting you or is he
responding to your rejection of him
like is it that he doesn't he's not
super thrilled about spending time with
you
because he knows that the moment he you
know is a little bit annoying you're
gonna pick up the phone or you say
you're crying every day are you crying a
lot in front of the kid too
he might he might not be super
enthusiastic about spending time with
you then
can you blame him the thing is it it
doesn't matter
anyway he's four he's going to act like
a four-year-old
four-year-old's wine it's what they do
four-year-olds are allowed to cry every
day i don't think adults should be
um but for a four-year-old that's their
language they don't have anything else
that's their that you know crying and
whining
for a four-year-old that's their
language that's their custom their
tradition
the custom of their people you're
whining too
right now whining in fact is a human
language we all do it
holding whining against a four-year-old
is is really ridiculous for that reason
so even if he's the one who started it
by not wanting to hang out with you
so what get off your damn phone put some
sustained effort into it
if you can't entertain a four-year-old
then that's just a that's a sad state of
affairs they are the
they're the easy easiest humans to
entertain by far
you never thought covid could cost you
your home right it just might because
cyber crime is up 75
and by far the most serious cyber crime
to worry about is home title theft
that's right cyber criminals
foreign and domestic are now after our
homes and it's easier than you think the
title documents to our homes are online
now the thief
finds your home's title forces your
signature on a
quit claim deed stating you sold your
home to him
then he takes out loans on your home and
leaves you in debt you won't
know until late payments or eviction
notices arrive insurance
doesn't cover you and neither do common
identity theft programs
that's why i protect my home with home
title lock the instant home title lock
detects someone tampering with my home's
title to help shut it down right away go
to
hometitlelock.com and register your
address to see if you're
already a victim then use code walsh to
receive 30 free days of protection
that's codewalsh at
hometitlelock.comhometitleluck.com
codewalsh this one says we have three
girls aged two months
almost two and four and a half the
youngest is sleeping through the night
half the time
don't hate me so i feel we should move
her into her own room sooner than later
i figured we'd have another couple of
months so now i'm scrambling to move our
two-year-old out of her room and into
her sister's room
we got them bunk beds but man i'm so
scared they're going to keep each other
up
is it going to be pure chaos with them
in one room together they both have
separate nighttime routines and go to
bed at different times right now
help okay two and four year old oh yeah
they're gonna keep each other up
they will keep each other up wake each
other up
they're gonna be up at 4 30 in the
morning every morning
better believe it it's gonna it's gonna
be so bad
and it's gonna be that way for a long
time it's gonna last
years of this
so avoid putting kids together if you
can i firmly believe that
if you can't though then buckle up grin
and bear it
sleep is for the weak that's what you
got to tell yourself adopt that attitude
it's not true
it's ridiculous i mean you need to sleep
or die but
you have to tell yourself that just to
survive mentally
that's what i've had to do our
seven-year-old and our four-year-old
sons share a room and i don't think
they've actually slept since last march
i don't know if they've slept at all
they're they're up late
they wake up at like four in the morning
we're all going slowly insane in our
house
please help me i just want to sleep but
i guess i'm supposed to be the one
giving advice right now so um
we'll get we'll put that to the side
here's what i would say look on the
bright side
they're girls so girls are more docile
they'll probably wake up at 4 30 in the
morning but they'll stay in their rooms
brushing each other's hair doing a tea
party with the dolls whatever it is
my boys are up literally bouncing off
the walls i don't say that as an
expression or figure speech
actually bouncing running into the walls
the other day i walked into the room
and my seven-year-old son said to me hey
daddy watch this and then he just ran
and hit the wall
on purpose that's what boys do so you
don't have that be grateful
let's see finally last question how do i
prevent my child from peeing on me when
i change his diaper
well you could try a strategically
placed traffic cone
right over the danger zone that's one
thing you could do
i'll tell you what my strategy is um i
just here's what i do it's really
interesting
i just never change the diaper to begin
with
i avoid at all costs changing a diaper
so this is a whole category of problems
that i don't have to deal with i
typically will look the other way
when there's a dirty diaper and i'll let
my wife discover the problem
and look it's not something i do for me
i want to be clear about that
this is not selfishness on my part this
is
something that i do because i know my
wife
cherishes those bonding moments with her
children
and that's so important to me that is so
important to me for her to have those
moments
and those are the sacrifices that i'm
willing to make for those that i love
and that's what parenting is all about
it's about making
sacrifices and that's the message i want
you to take from this